Ein ehemaliger Wachturm in Berlin –
heute ein Ort für die Kunst.
Die einstige Sperrzone im Grenzgebiet:
Daneben liegt heute ein
alternatives Stadtquartier.
Dort, wo die Mauer die Menschen trennte,
befinden sich heute etliche Kulturstätten.
Hallo,
ich bin Euromaxx-Reporterin Diana Piñeros.
Ich werde Ihnen vier Orte zeigen,
an denen nach dem Mauerfall
etwas Neues entstanden ist.
Los geht's!
Im früheren Ostteil der Stadt ist jetzt das
Künstlerdorf Holzmarkt 25 ansässig.
Im Schatten der Mauer war
das Areal ein Niemandsland.
Lange passiert nichts.
2003 entsteht auf dem Brachland
zunächst ein Techno-Club
und später das Kulturzentrum.
Also, ich glaub, der Holzmarkt,
der konnte nur hier entstehen,
nur in Berlin und auch nur an diesem Ort.
Hier konnte ganz lange keine Stadt
wachsen, das war ’ne Narbe.
Und daraus hat man natürlich
’ne Situation vorgefunden,
dass man Gestaltungsspielräume
hatte, dass es Freiräume gab,
die noch nicht bebaut waren und
die noch nicht beplant waren.
Insgesamt 302 Wachtürme
standen auf dem Todesstreifen
und waren Teil eines brutalen Grenzsystems.
Heutzutage sind nur noch wenige erhalten.
Von diesem Wachturm wurde einst die
Grenze zwischen dem Ostberliner Bezirk
Treptow und dem Westberliner Bezirk
Kreuzberg kontrolliert.
Heute ist der Turm ein Ort der Kunst
und steht unter Denkmalschutz.
So sah der Wachturm nach dem Mauerfall
aus, und so sieht es heute aus.
Es ist unglaublich, sich vorzustellen,
dass vor 60 Jahren von Türmen wie diesen
auf Menschen geschossen wurde.
Ui, schwer!
Wow, verrückt!
In dem zehn Meter hohen Bau befinden sich
inzwischen Ateliers für Kunstschaffende.
Auch Ausstellungen und Events
finden hier regelmäßig statt.
Der geschichtsträchtige Ort wird vom
Künstlerkollektiv „The Watch“ betreut.
Warum ist es so wichtig, Kunst hier
in einem Wachturm auszustellen?
Also, den Turm zu aktivieren, ist wichtig,
weil wir jetzt, 30 – mehr als 30 Jahre
nach dem Mauerfall,
nämlich eine neue Frage von solchen
Symboliken erarbeiten müssen.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich, 2021
in einem ehemaligen Turm,
der einem Grenzapparat
zugehörte, zu arbeiten?
Es ist wichtig, da Künstler
und Künstlerinnen einzuladen,
die immer wieder diesen Ort irgendwie
neu besetzen und neu definieren.
Und natürlich ist die East Side Gallery
immer einen Besuch wert.
1,3 Kilometer – das längste noch
erhaltene Stück der Mauer in Berlin.
Heute auf der früheren Ostseite:
eine Freiluftgalerie.
Die Bilder wurden erst nach dem Mauerfall
gemalt.
Zu DDR-Zeiten war das unmöglich.
Am Spreeufer sind viele Cafés
und Grünflächen entstanden.
Die Mauer kann man sich hier auch von der
unbemalten Rückseite anschauen.
Ich habe die East Side Gallery
schon oft gesehen,
aber noch nie aus dieser Perspektive.
Ich kann mir Berlin nicht als
geteilte Stadt vorstellen.
Sogar auf dem Wasser gab
es einen Grenzverlauf.
Hier, wo sich heute auf der Spree
ein schwimmender Pool befindet,
patrouillierten einst Grenzsoldaten
mit Booten auf dem Fluss.
Das „Badeschiff“ ist städtisches
Kulturprojekt und Touristenmagnet.
Diana Piñeros trifft den Architekten
und die Kuratorin.
Warum haben Sie sich
für diesen Ort entschieden?
Das hängt eben mit
dem Grenzverlauf zusammen.
Und der Grenzverlauf war eben
natürlicherweise die Spree.
Das hat natürlich auch viel mit der
Wassersituation gemacht,
und wir wollten diesen Zugang wieder öffnen.
Reste der ehemaligen Grenzanlage auf der
Spree
kann man
heute noch von hier sehen.
Heute habe ich sehr viel gelernt,
und ich bin ganz begeistert,
was nach dem Mauerfall alles Neues
in Berlin entstanden ist.
Und jetzt, [da] ich schon hier bin,
muss ich natürlich eine Runde
schwimmen gehen.
Uiuiui,
es ist schon ein bisschen frisch.
Aber der Blick ist wunderschön!